[Music]
on this saturday night
slow vaccination in our nation pfizer
claims it has to cut the doses it's
delivering to canada
we'll have to make decisions about how
best to optimize
who gets vaccine but the drug company
makes a different promise
to europe the difficult decisions facing
icu doctors in ontario
we really have been ground zero for coba
patients
in ontario the pressure on intensive
care
in a province with a high caseload of
kova 19.
the barricades are up in dc and other
u.s
capitals i'm sad about it i have to tell
you that it that it looks that way
fortifying america for a safe transition
of power what will we do
and hooked on old fishing songs these
songs are sailing across that sea
the return of the sea shanty
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us provinces are scrambling to figure
out the next steps in their vaccination
efforts canada was caught off guard when
pfizer biontech cut the number of doses
to be delivered to this country
in an effort to ramp up its
manufacturing capacity
the drug company says we can expect a 50
reduction over the next four weeks so
those who already had their first dose
may have to wait longer for the second
shot but as david aiken discovered
the pharmaceutical giant told some
european countries
the impact for them will be less drastic
the problem is in belgium that's where
pfizer biontech makes all of the
vaccines that are shipped to canada and
most european countries pfizer biotech
needs to upgrade its belgian plant so it
can make
more vaccines faster this expansion work
means that pfizer
is temporarily reducing deliveries to
all countries
receiving vaccine manufactured at its
european facility
and that includes canada pfizer biontech
told canada and its european customers
they would only be getting half as much
vaccine as expected
for the next four weeks that was where
things stood
friday morning but by late friday pfizer
biontext
outraged european customers had won a
change
and pfizer biontech issued a statement
saying we will be
back to the original schedule of
deliveries to the european union
beginning the week of january the 25th
but even though
canada gets its vaccines from the same
factory as
europe it wasn't clear if canada 2
will be back to regular shipments of
pfizer biontech
in one week we are once again in touch
with representatives from pfizer to
reiterate firmly the importance for
canada to return to our
regular delivery schedule as soon as
possible
procurement minister anita anand said in
a statement to global news
pfizer assured us that it is deploying
all efforts to do just that
pfizer biontech did not respond to
requests for clarification in any event
any delays in a pfizer biontech shipment
could be a problem for provinces like bc
that did not reserve the required second
dose for those who have already received
their first dose we will be looking at
how much vaccine is coming in how many
people are due to get their vaccine in
that week
when are those weeks when we might have
less than we're expecting
and then we'll have to make decisions
about how best to optimize
who gets vaccine at that time canada's
chief public health officials say
it's okay to give the second dose as
much as
42 days later and that's what ontario is
planning to do for some
in that province in the meantime the
rollout of the
moderna vaccine should continue
uninterrupted
canada received thousand doses of
that vaccine this week and is expecting
two hundred and thirty thousand more
modernity doses
in the first week of february david
aiken global news
ottawa ontario's coveted 19k slowed
increased by more than 3 000 new
infections today
that's 11 straight days of numbers that
high
there are fears the province's intensive
care units will soon be pushed to the
brink
especially in the greater toronto area
as morgan campbell reports
some patients are being flown out of the
gta as
icu's become overloaded
a surge in the number of covet 19
positive patients
in need of critical care is putting an
intense strain
on ontario's health care system already
under
immense pressure i didn't think i would
ever be in a situation where we would be
transferring patients to other hospitals
for admission
or to the icu or transferring patient to
other neighboring cities
lisa solomon is an emergency room
physician with the scarborough health
network where many doctors are worried
about capacity issues in the intensive
care units
we're seeing really sick patients with
covid and in addition we're seeing
really sick patients in general with
other presenting issues friday the
health network admitted its
300th patient to the icu
the lack of space has forced doctors to
send some of those patients
to kingston general hospital for
treatments nearly
three hours away when the
sort of the word came out that we would
likely get patients from out of area
the government has asked us to reserve
about a third of our existing
open capacity kingston general hospital
has recently expanded its capacity for
icu beds earlier this month the province
asked hospital ceos to prepare for
out-of-region patients and to share
resources with hospitals overwhelmed by
the virus
hospitals were also directed to accept
any patient transfers
this practice is common dating back well
before the pandemic
but doctors say not to the extent they
are experiencing
right now as they try and sort of share
the responsibility of caring for these
patients across
the province the closer hospitals get
filled up sooner and then you start to
look to sending them to places that are
maybe less affected and have a little
bit more capacity at the time
provincial modeling shows icu admissions
could exceed a thousand
in less than a month which means these
patient transfers
will likely continue morgan campbell
global news toronto
inspectors have begun a blitz on big box
stores in ontario to make sure staff and
customers are sticking to public health
measures
the inspectors are looking to make sure
people are wearing masks and maintaining
physical
distancing if they break the rules they
face fines up to 750 dollars
inspectors also the authority to
disperse groups of more than five people
and shut down stores that breached the
rules
just days before president-elect joe
biden's inauguration police in
washington have arrested a virginia man
trying to get through a checkpoint near
the capitol building
a 31-year-old was found with fake
inaugural credentials a loaded handgun
and more than 500 rounds of ammunition
it's tense in the u.s
capitol after the riots earlier this
month and now tens of thousands of
soldiers are patrolling the streets of
d.c
here's jennifer johnson
national guard troops from washington
state are heading to washington d.c
as federal agencies order more troops
deployed to protect the nation's capital
ahead of inauguration day our troops are
going there to support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
washington d.c looks like a war zone
with at least 25 thousand soldiers
patrolling the city
the coast guard is battle ready on the
potomac river
miles of fencing and barbed wire
surround the capitol
god bless you all and keep you safe and
may god protect our troops
thank you just days before he will be
sworn into office
president-elect biden answered yes after
being asked if he still felt safe
but sunday's inauguration dress
rehearsal has been canceled
the day will be like no other but the
first time in u.s history the national
mall where hundreds of thousands of
people usually watch the event will be
closed
most metro rail lines have been stopped
airbnb
has canceled all dc reservations every
street leading into the capitol is
barricaded
i'm sad about it i have to tell you that
it that it looks that way
i'm committed to making sure that we
we get our city back as part of
inauguration day festivities the
canadian embassy usually hosts a
celebration for foreign dignitaries
that too has been cancelled due to the
pandemic and security concerns
many d.c residents are worried i don't
know
what to expect other than i'm just
afraid someone
or many people are going to get killed
president trump is refusing to abide by
tradition
and will skip the inauguration as staff
starts to move out the president remains
quiet
at the white house ahead of his
wednesday morning departure
aides are considering an elaborate
send-off with a red carpet
military ban and 21-gun salute
jennifer johnson global news washington
security is ramping up right across the
u.s tonight
the fbi warns trump supporters may
target all 50 state capitals on
wednesday
and preparations are underway for
potential armed protests
as early as tomorrow tonight mike
armstrong is in harrisburg pennsylvania
and as he explains no one wants to be
caught off guard
again there isn't a whole lot to see
from the street outside the pennsylvania
state capitol complex
barriers and not a whole lot else but
behind the scenes it's
all hands on deck capitol police city
police state police and the national
guard
all are preparing for sunday we are not
issuing any permits so there are no
protests scheduled here there are no
specific threats against harrisburg
or any other state capitol but there
have been flyers
circulating online suggesting protesters
who can't make it to washington sunday
go instead to their state capitol since
the january sixth siege in washington
and the arrests that followed
the calls to arms online have died down
authorities fear that could just be
protest planners being more secretive
and careful online i think that's why
some of the um
chatter has stopped i think that's why
some of the platforms have
changed right now it's a chess game
literally from coast to coast state
capitals are preparing from lansing
michigan
to sacramento california from austin in
texas
to tallahassee in florida again there
are no specific threats but
america is on alert in case now i am
hopeful that we do not experience any
violence in the capital city this
weekend or next
but hope is not a plan the protection
outside the capitals is only a part of
what's going on the fbi is collecting
intelligence whatever it can find
and sharing it with local and state
police the intelligence is key
you want to have the ability to develop
a plan but you also want to have
as much knowledge about the intent and
capability
of the people that are going to show up
one thing that does have police nervous
is a line in this flyer calling it an
armed march telling people to show up
with weapons
in an open carry state like here in
pennsylvania police admit that does make
things more
delicate but they say they have the
training and sunday they'll have the
numbers
to deal with anything robin micah i'm
strong in pennsylvania tonight thanks
mike
canada will have a representative at the
inauguration the two countries have long
been
allies but the last four years have been
tense so our relationship with a new
administration will be very
important abigail beeman spoke with
canada's ambassador to the u.s
kirsten hillman on the west block
abigail robin in an inauguration like no
other with beefed up security and in the
middle of a pandemic
ambassador kirsten hillman says she will
be there in person
all attendees will be getting a coven 19
test
first but in terms of the actual work
she
has in front of her after the ceremony
getting the biden administration's
attention for canada could be a
challenge after the chaos of a
transition to power
like no other ambassador hillman says
conversations are already underway
reaching out and getting into the biden
executive team was going to be very
important to us
we have been spending months getting
ready for that
the biden team themselves the appointees
and the nominees have been very
respectful
of the fact that there's only one u.s
administration at a time and it remains
the trump administration until
until wednesday at noon but we have been
able to talk to many members of their
transition team and people that are
advising them
to to start to lay the groundwork for
those first
calls and that first outreach i also
asked the ambassador how she'll push
canada's interests on files that clash
with the incoming president's agenda
such as the keystone xl pipeline
hillman says she will have honest and
fact-based conversations you can catch
her entire answer and the full interview
sunday
on the west block robin abigail beeman
in ottawa thanks abigail
global news will have live coverage of
the inauguration from washington d.c on
wednesday morning
at 11 eastern 8 pacific
coming up the world's largest
vaccination campaign begins in
india and uganda's long-serving
president
hangs onto power
the search for survivors continues in
indonesia friday's 6.2 magnitude
earthquake on the island of sulawesi
injured hundreds of people and killed at
least 49.
the death toll is expected to grow as
rescue teams dig through the debris
damaged roads power blackouts and a lack
of heavy equipment are hampering their
efforts
nearly 15 thousand people have been
displaced by the quake
and they're desperate for shelter and
supplies
mount semaru indonesia's highest volcano
on the island of java spewed hot clouds
into the sky there were no evacuations
or reported injuries after weeks of
violence uganda's longtime president
yawari lusaveni has secured his sixth
term in office
his supporters celebrated in the streets
the 76 year old won 59 percent of the
vote
but his rival a musician-turned
politician known as bobby wine
claims the election was rigged the
opposition leader remains under heavy
guard
and his party says he's effectively
under house arrest
in the lead-up to the vote dozens were
killed and the country's internet was
shut down
musaveni has been in power for 35 years
he's been accused of ordering
violent crackdowns to silence critics
in the u.k a cathedral has been
transformed into a vaccination center
in the middle ages sick people would go
on a pilgrimage to this cathedral
in the hopes of being healed now
hundreds of people are passing through
its doors to receive the coven 19
vaccine
this is just one of several major
buildings in england repurposed for the
vaccine rollout
the uk government hopes to vaccinate
about 14 million people
by february 15th india has kicked off
what's expected to be the world's
largest coven 19 vaccination campaign
more than 150 000 frontline health care
workers received the vaccine today
the government hopes to give the vaccine
to 300 million people
by july to put that into context
that's roughly eight times the
population of canada
still ahead the experts weigh in on
whether coba 19 patients
need to get vaccinated
for nearly a year now global news has
been taking your coven 19
questions straight to doctors they've
tackled countless
topics including how the virus is
transmitted
mask use and how canadians can keep
themselves safe
tonight jeff semple takes more of your
questions to the experts
why does zayn always wear a jacket to
make us look bad huh isaac
for months now these four friends and
infectious disease doctors
have been answering viewer questions
about covid19
and a lot of the questions lately are
focused on vaccines
hi i'm laurie from calgary my question
is
if someone has had covid and they've
recovered
do they still need to get vaccinated
right now
we know that people who are exposed to
the virus do develop some type of
immunity
how long it lasts how good it is and how
effective it is at preventing
reinfection
if you run into this virus again is not
quite clear
and so the take home message and best
advice right now
is that even if you've had copic 19
before
please get your vaccine hi my name is
elsa holland
i live in yoho new brunswick i currently
receive
treatments for breast cancer has the
vaccine been tested on people
taking cancer treatments that suppress
their immune systems
and we've received a lot of questions
like that from people who are
immunocompromised obese or have
pre-existing health conditions
and are wondering if the vaccine will be
safe for them dr
chegler so these are done in clinical
trials with relatively healthy people
there were people with
you know a small number with hiv a small
number with obesity a small number of
diabetes and high blood pressure that
were incorporated into these studies and
you know not enough to say that there's
any big difference but certainly there
wasn't any difference that was seen
in those responses amongst those
individuals my question today
is about hand washing in this new
phase of the pandemic we don't hear
anything about hand washing anymore
i think as time went on and we learned
more it became more apparent that
getting covert from surfaces where it's
not impossible to do so
i think the big risk to know is that
covert is spread
primarily in indoor settings when you're
in a
close enclosed space especially with
poor ventilation
and for a prolonged period of time
you're not really going to get it by
touching a shopping cart uh
going to get groceries love you guys i
gotta go
thanks everybody bye after yet another
round of covid 19
questions it's back to yet another day
on the front lines of the pandemic jeff
semple global news mississauga ontario
what's your favorite sea shanty there
once was a ship that put to see
up next the old sea songs that have the
world
on board
hey everybody welcome back let's say
hello to our friend mr john batiste
john are you aware that 2021 is the year
of the sea shanty
oh my goodness it's the year to see
shanty really i can't believe
even stephen colbert is talking about
sea shanties
these folk songs date back hundreds of
years sailors would sing them while
working through rough conditions
well the tunes have made a comeback
they've brought people together
in these modern troubled times here's
ross lord
on this popular social media platform
people are breathing new life
into old fishing songs known as sea
shanties
remakes are getting millions of views
reviving interest in songs created
centuries ago
what will we do with the drunken sailor
what will we do with the drunken
see sanis have always gone hand in hand
with hardship
[Music]
[Applause]
a way for sailors to get the job done in
bitter working conditions
using different rhythms for different
jobs
use a sheet shanty like whiskey johnny
oh
whiskey is the life of man whiskey
johnny so those quick pulls that'll pull
that
sheet in and you'll get the sail trimmed
their resurrection
at the height of the covet 19 pandemic
is no coincidence
according to some folk historians i
think people need
things to lighten up a bit so they
they need they need a bit more enjoyment
something that they can get
get into and something to help them get
through tough times according to sean
mccann
as a singer songwriter and former member
of the newfoundland folk group
great big c mccann's nickname was the
shanty man
there's a sea of social media and
but it's still these songs are sailing
across that sea
they're just doing it really fast how
long this infatuation lasts is anyone's
guess
but for those who've invested most of
their lives in sea shanties
seeing that passion shared by millions
of others
is heartwarming so give a sailor not
your heart
lest sorrow you do seek
let true love not be torn apart
by favors from the sea
stay calm shanty on ross lord
global news shantion that is global
national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
bonus park
in calgary thank you for watching and
i'll see you back here tomorrow
have a great night